hi I'm Garth DeAngelis senior producer
on war of the chosen the expansion to
XCOM 2
far from the new and gleaming city
centers there are still scars from the
first invasion these ruined cities are
home to the lost and abandoned to
reclaim earth you will have to get
opposing factions to put aside their
differences to counter the strength of
the chosen in this mission we introduced
the Reapers sharpshooters and masters of
concealment we also have the skirmishers
who were once Advent soldiers now they
fight their own past getting these
factions to work together over their
mutual mistrust won't be easy at the
start of the mission you'll have to
escort representatives of these groups
to a meeting this means choosing two
teams to make contact with each faction
it's up to you to make sure the
rendezvous goes off without a hitch
the Reapers will send out rider to meet
your first team your job will be to
bring her to the rendezvous point alive
as you move towards the rendezvous point
you'll have your first encounter with
the lost the lost attack in large groups
but when you kill a loss with a headshot
this restores your action with
successive headshots a soldier can kill
multiple lost in a turn but you'll need
to pick your shots wisely and keep an
eye on your ammo the lost are drawn to
the sounds of combat making explosives
of risky choice each time you set up an
explosion more loss will swarm on your
position your second team will escort
mocks the representative of the
skirmishers here you'll encounter
purifiers Advent specialists against the
lost you'll also discover that machs
takes a less stealthy explosive approach
to combat you'll need to keep mocs alive
to the extraction point before you're
overwhelmed the skirmishers and reapers
don't trust each other but they well
work together to defeat a common enemy
and you'll have your hands full
against the assassin she's one of the
elders chosen powerful champions of the
elders sent to hunt down XCOM each time
you encounter are chosen they'll have
different strengths and weaknesses the
assassin specializes in stealth and
melee combat she'll try to daze your
troops before abducting and
interrogating them
get those soldiers up before they're
taken the fight with the assassin will
be tough if you don't keep your
strengths and weaknesses at the heart of
your plan you're going to come out of
the fight wounded at best and you'll
need your strength because the missions
not over yet swarms of loss will start
to appear as you fight your way to the
extraction point
keep cool you're not going to be able to
kill all of it if you rush straight to
the evac you're going to get overwhelmed
steady incremental progress and
understanding how to make the most of
the headshot are your keys to the fight
here remember the loss don't use cover
and only have melee attacks you can
prioritize positioning and shot success
over defensive cover and overwatch this
is a walking gunfight reaching the evac
point will be a huge relief but the
Chosin may have one last unpleasant
surprise for you one that may affect the
course of the rest of your game
good luck commander
you
you